beat people killing people I got angry
with him sirs why are you laughing
six me came to the house gently rip to
us today then talk of their experiences
was quite heroin huge amounts of
bloodshed and rape and other atrocities
women and children crying one day if
you're a child in South Sudan it's an
extremely dangerous country this is a
historic moment the people of others who
don't have been waiting for South Sudan
is the world's youngest nation literally
only just been born given to us by the
Almighty God there was so much optimism
is that new beginning is others this is
gonna be a bright new future for a
wonderful new nation which could now go
forward develop and grow none of that
has really happened
from its inception it has been torn
apart
by war by famine
everything that could happen to South
Sudan has pretty much happened to it and
its people have suffered
I went shortly after their independence
how I does it
it was extremely caught it was extremely
undeveloped
and very very primitive almost
immediately they were fighting with
their former brothers in Sudan armies
from both sides all massing on the
border there were lots of soldiers being
injured and having to be carted off and
nothing much was developing nothing much
was progressing because they were
spending so much time fighting the other
country within two years the whole thing
had fallen apart
and civil war had broken out today marks
the end of the world in the Republic of
South Sudan when we went back after the
latest peace deal we were hoping to see
some real change but actually there were
underlying things that were exactly the
same depressingly the same
[Music]
my first time in South Sudan so I was
coming at this cold what happened there
sounded pretty damn horrific there are a
load of challenges in covering what was
happening in South Sudan one was the
lack of infrastructure and getting to
places which are just phenomenally
difficult to get to because there are no
roads it's very difficult to reach them
there is no show chilled flight surface
there's no domestic flights in many of
these cases you need to find a plane and
find someone who's willing to fly the
plane to take you from A to B
it's a salon pretty undeveloped we have
to fly in on a small plane to get where
we need you to go and from there you can
take a vehicle so far that a lot of the
places you have to take the riverboats
but after that it's be basic it's a
really difficult environment operating
with very high temperatures risk of
impromptu discontent amongst the local
population as soon as we walk into an
area like this which is poverty-stricken
and we are relatively rich foreigners we
are immediately an issue because we're
ripe for exploitation we're right for
kidnap were right for being taken
advantage of South Sudan has got an
astonishing number of its population
which is not living in the place where
it started out there's like a third of
the country has moved or has been
displaced living in very very difficult
circumstances away from home
[Music]
just for a little bit I think that UN
have a very difficult role because they
opened up their gates to these people
who desperately needed help and felt
like the UN was the only safe refuge
that they had at that time civilians
especially women and children came fast
crying one day came inside the UN
compound my charcoal de humedad
ya batana de Sala madam they probably
thought this would only last for few
weeks a few months and it's gone on for
years and no one wants to leave because
they don't feel safe outside the UN camp
that we visited we could see from the
watchtower just how big this place is
and it was much bigger and much more
organized than I imagined it would be
there's obviously been there for some
years now the camp itself is behind
barbed wire and it just feels horrible
really and these people have just got
squares of space to live in and
literally for their safety
they've got troops driving up and down
in jeeps patrolling
[Music]
school kids under armed guard being
taken for their exams which was off-site
and then being escorted back again
you know I think similar six or 700
school kids late teens it's not long the
living conditions are not what anyone
wants to live in no matter where you are
around the world the heat was oppressive
these people they're choosing to be in
an armed camp because that's safe it'll
probably be years before they get to
move back to any sort of normality one
very tall woman really stood out when we
were watching her pump the water
she kept on saying come on come on it's
back-breaking work and then she insisted
Alex join in so eventually you can
actually avoid going up and doing it
with her
[Music]
I felt she's slightly taking the Mickey
to pain relishing the fact that I was
really struggling to push the water but
we had an instant rapport I'm not really
sure why and so we said can you please
show us around the camp she wanted to
show us her side of things as well so we
followed her she was a bit of a
character can we go to her her tent an
incredible woman really because she had
seven children it later transpired that
she only had one child with her how old
is their land of mindfulness and I
thought maybe this is because her
children have all grown up and they've
left her no she's lost them all so her
other children where are they did she
get separated from them as they were
fleeing and running away from the
fighting and just trying to get to
safety you've only got one with you the
rest are all separated okay LuAnn I got
a thank you welcome although she gave
this appearance of being very strong and
she seemed to be really in control of
herself when we were inside the tent
talking to her I didn't realize she was
really getting quite emotional because
she was quite sort of straightforward
about it and then I realized she was
upset really upset
I'm also really scared about going out
do you feel scared still now growl along
common error am i doing her work where
the gravity of these situations where
these people are locked into that
situation they don't wish to be in that
situation there was no fighting on the
ground where we were some peace was
holding but you get the feeling that it
wouldn't take a huge amount of things to
clap
[Music]
we couldn't really go to South Sudan
without focusing on the issue of child
soldiers
[Music]
because it's got one of the largest
number of child soldiers in the world
whilst it's got an ongoing humanitarian
disaster unfolding every day it's also
got this huge big challenge of dealing
with coping with and rehabilitating the
thousands and thousands of young
children who've been forced into picking
up arms and fighting of course
internationally this constitutes a war
crimes especially for children who are
underage below the age of 18 and some of
them are 14 of that team recruited
introduced we set out to visit a very
remote area to follow up on the story of
child soldiers and some of the horrors
that happen out in the countryside
we went to a center where former child
soldiers are being retrained being
taught new skills to try to help them
reintegrate into society one go we spoke
to in particular who's only 17 or 18 I
think was clearly self-conscious
wherever not he was at the time we don't
know but he he was very shy and he
struggled to explain what had happened
were you ordered to to rape women you
know he had been forced to to rape some
girls how many times do you realize
they're children as well at the time and
they're being forced to do stuff they
wouldn't necessarily want to do
different women she sort of just trotted
it off yeah no I raped about four or
five he seemed to know it was wrong but
he still spoke about it in a very calm
way and that was very chilling saddening
but when people now my gun
it was it's really staggering thank you
another young guy that we spoke to did
whitey there was he was just laughing
about who had killed before killing
people I got I got angry with him who
did you kill
why why why are you loving why are you
smiling you killed somebody in your
laughing why are you laughing why is
this funny
tell me it's quite hard not to get angry
with these young men but actually their
victims - they're very very damaged
individuals themselves and I think
they're all that are all very
emotionally scarred
they've lost their compass on everything
so they don't really know what's right
and what's wrong probably being terribly
frightened and I'm not even sure they
really they really know what they've
done to hear then talk of their
experiences was quite harrowing without
a doubt rape is used as a weapon there
are something like 19,000 child soldiers
in South Sudan and all of those child
soldiers a fairly high proportion of
females and almost all of those women
girls will have been raped or sexually
assaulted in the rehabilitation centre
I'm pretty sure there wasn't a single
young girl had not been raped most of
them had suffered multiple rapes many of
them had their babies on their knee
which when you then think all of those
babies have come as a product of rape by
soldiers it's hard to get your head
around that
how many men do you think raped you do
it for four I think as a journalist that
can be nothing worse than talking to
women who've been through such horrible
violence atrocities which let's face it
are a war crime for girls who are
sleeping in then from there six men came
to to the house where were sleeping
Gentile raped us and they can't be
anything worse for female journalists
than talking to another female who's
suffered from that if you refuse they
will tell you and if they will beat you
and also at the same the center didn't
give you women were raped by people in
uniform using rape as a weapon or fire
of war how did you get pregnant I was
being raped in who and I conceived they
were so monotone and quite calm just
talking how they had been raped and
violated and abused and it was just
almost matter of fact there's really
quite upsetting and what you keep on
having to remind yourself is all of them
are children
they're just children and many of these
things that happened when they were 15
16 17 one girl we saw who was pregnant
and a couple of months of giving birth
and she was still only 15
[Music]
another girl we spoke to she described
when she was first raped after she was
seized by the fighters when did it
happen the first night how many were
there there were five
[Music]
when I first saw that girl I thought
what a sweet young woman she is
and he actually lived more than most
grown-up women she'd been through so
much and she's somehow survived as she
was telling her story she kept on
looking at the camera and that's a
little unusual as she was describing
these horrible things she was just
staring down the lens and it was
haunting almost anew now bill did some
houses they ended up taking me to their
house the details we were being told
were horrendous the composure she had
for somebody who was so young
it's hard it's probably one of the
hardest things we can do is get people
to reveal something so horrific that you
know it's just uncomfortable talking
amongst ourselves about the subject but
then to talk about what they experienced
it's really probably one of the hardest
things we do no job
to see her little face no I was saying
things like how do you feel towards the
baby and she immediately knew what I was
getting at home so happy the first day
she wants to build a life with her
little girl puts what happened to her
behind her she didn't want it to define
her my futures
we're done being that he's held nice my
doctor work tomorrow
what they've had to go through they've
grown up fast you know that their
childhood goes in the blink isn't it
I feel unhappy with stories of women
that have gone through their hands men
in uniforms we don't have respect for
any of our human value talking to those
women
[Music]
was actually quite inspiring because I'm
looking at them and I'm thinking would I
be able to forgive someone had done that
to me I don't think so I really don't
think so
and yet they were much younger all four
things had happened to them they had
babies as a result of being violated and
yet they were ready and had forgiven I
don't want something bad to happen to
him just like what will keep the amazing
forget them for one trapped it do you
forgive them yeah I forgive him somebody
has done that to them and no one should
be allowed to do that whether it's in
war or whether it's in peace
[Music]
it's quite hard to see hope it's really
quite hard for many of these people
there is no peace they've got to live
with these babies from rape they've got
to live with these emotional scars the
peace is fragile there's no guarantee
that it's going to last there's still a
lot more to do there's still thousands
of child soldiers there's still
thousands of women being held
it's a long journey of recovery that
need to go underway
I think South Sudan it's now got a
legacy of people a whole generation of
being scarred by what's happened but
there is a small chance they can come
through because if that generation is
made up of those people that we saw and
spoke to then there is just a chance
that they can come through it
and that means but there is actually
hope
you